hello people of the internet
this is the reuben report direct message
i'm dave rubin all right
three stories today i always tell you
it'll be between two and four stories
we're smack dab in the middle
with three today and uh one of them
the first story that i'm going to talk
about today is about kyle rittenhouse
he's the 17 year old
that you may remember from the kenosha
wisconsin riots now
these riots actually originally happened
in
august and i was off the grid for that
this was one of the stories
that michael knowles got me caught up to
speed on when i came back on the grid
so i didn't even know about the riots as
they were happening
so i think that perhaps i have a little
bit of a clearer perspective
on this because i'm sort of getting all
the information
uh post it happening you know one of the
problems we have is when
stories break you get a gajillion
sources and twitter people telling you a
gajillion different things
and you know some people see the same
video and see you know 10 different
things
in the same video and then they share
that and they clip that and the whole
thing in any event i was on sean hannity
last night and i was supposed to be on
to talk about some of the election stuff
and and biden and trump and all that
and about an hour before uh they said
that there was a video that was breaking
that they wanted me to talk about
and actually there was a video released
by
a group called fight back and this is a
legal
group that is defending kyle rittenhouse
and they released an 11 minute video
that basically tells a very different
story and i'll i'll give you some of the
details of the story when we get to it
in a moment
but in essence you're not going to
believe this guys but
perhaps perhaps the story that we've
been told about kyle rittenhouse
that he was just out there to shoot
people and kill people and raise havoc
and that he was somehow a white
supremacist or the rest of it
you're not going to believe this but
there's more to the story
and that's probably not true and it's
much more complex than that
uh tucker carlson actually was the first
one to release
some of the video last night then
hannity picked it up
i talked about it it's sort of catching
fire right now and and it might
just be another example of one of these
things where there's a story
and if it fits the narrative you know
the media loves it
in this case you know young white man
shooting people we love that kind of
story or
jesse smilette young black man being
attacked
we love that story but when things don't
quite fit the narrative the media
doesn't know what to do so don't
expect this video that has been released
and by the way we'll link
to the full video michael let's make
sure we link to the full 11 minute video
and i'm not saying every analysis in
that video is true either
but perhaps there is more to the story
than what you're seeing on mainstream
media
and everything else so we'll get to that
uh the big one that i want to talk about
today
though is actually pretty freaking
incredible and goes to the heart of
pretty much everything that i've been
talking about for the last
72 years roughly uh donald trump
president donald trump your president
you know i like when they
always say that the people with trump
derangement syndrome they always say
he's your president
well he's your president too guy um
well he yesterday uh issued an executive
action
removing critical race theory uh
from all federal contact contracts he
had actually done some version of this
about a week ago
and then expanded on it yesterday
we're gonna dive into what critical race
theory is but in
essence for these last few years as
there's been a whole bunch of us talking
about identity politics and why the
institutions are crumbling under it
and the and these awful things like the
1619 project pushing theories
that the united states was founded on
slavery we fought a freaking war to end
slavery not too long later
uh all of these terrible ideas that have
leaked into not only our our
federal government but our local
government they've most likely leaked
into the the
places that you work and our
corporations and everything else
well trump's removing them and one of
the things that i'm going to want to
talk about is i did a quick
scan of twitter uh this morning to see
how many
of the good liberals like the the idw
crew liberals who have been
you know yammering and screaming and
writing books and doing videos and
giving talks
about about identity politics
about the the negative effects of
critical race theory
um all of these things why the new york
times is crumbling
all of these things like they're all
connected these aren't just like
independent things floating in the
universe
well i did a quick scan of the the good
liberals uh they're good remaining
liberals right
and uh very few of them uh mentioned
anything about trump doing this
trump actually doing the thing that they
wanted to be done
for so long and i want to sort of relate
that back to
uh how everything sort of orbits around
trump and then finally the third story
is going to be sort of an amorphous
story
i just want to talk about registering to
vote i don't know if you know this but
very soon there's an election coming up
between two very old men um and uh well
one of them actually uh may not even
make it to the election he may he may
step down
for that lady um who the hell knows
what's going to happen but i want to
talk about registering to vote and why
you should vote and i'll tell you a kind
of funny story
about uh what happened to me and route
to voting
uh last time in 2016. all right so let's
back up
we're going to start with this kyle
rittenhouse story so let's do this to
start
last night tucker carlson broke the
story that there was this expanded video
it's an 11
minute video that's an explainer uh from
a group called fight back this is the
legal defense
team of kyle ridden house so you have to
take that as it is
okay you know you can take it with a
grain of salt but they released an 11
minute video which again we're going to
link to in in the bottom right now
so that you'll be able to see the full
thing but i want to show you tucker has
a had a two-minute
uh lead up to it with just a bite of the
video and i just want to play that and
then we'll talk about inside police did
little to stop
the destruction a small number of
citizens decided to fill the vacuum
one of them was a 17 year old from
suburban chicago called kyle rittenhouse
on tuesday august 25th rittenhouse
finished his shift as a lifeguard in
kenosha
video shows he spent part of that day
cleaning graffiti from the walls of a
local high school
ridden house then went downtown with a
rifle to try to protect a car dealership
that been
attacked by mobs the night before what
happened next destroyed kyle
rittenhouse's life
it also ended the lives of two other
people kyle rittenhouse apparently shot
three people total two of them fatally
his attorneys argue that kyle
rittenhouse acted in self-defense
prosecutors in wisconsin charged him
with first degree murder
so what is the truth about what happened
that night
this is one of those rare cases when we
might be able to reach
firm conclusions about that before the
trial
there was an enormous amount of video
shot that night in kenosha mostly by
citizens with iphones
we have video of all three of the
shootings kyle rittenhouse was involved
in
critically we also have video of the
moments that preceded
those shootings the context we've
already showed some of that video to you
but tonight
we're going to show you more new
never-before-seen footage of kyle
rittenhouse in kenosha
now what you're about to see comes from
the non-profit fight back that was
formed by rittenhouse's defamation
attorney
lynn wood for the last month there's
been an enormous amount of propaganda
surrounding this case and virtually all
of it has come from the left
congresswoman ayanna presley of
massachusetts for example denounced kyle
rittenhouse
as quote a white supremacist domestic
terrorist
now there's no evidence that is true
there never has been
any evidence it's a lie so far as we
know
so the question is what else are they
lying about tonight we're going to show
you context from that night and we're
going to let you decide what happened
here to begin is video of kyle
rittenhouse hours before the shootings
took place
now again what you're about to see comes
from a group a non-profit
founded by kyle rittenhouse's defamation
attorney here it is
to prevent the total destruction of
their community
good samaritans united to guard local
businesses
among them was 17 year old kyle
rittenhouse
so people are getting injured okay so
obviously tucker gave you a little
context there showed a little bit of the
video
now if you if you watch the 11 minute
thing and i'm sure it's going to go up
on bit shoot or
something somewhere i'm not saying it's
all true
you know what i mean like they might
have done some selectively selective
editing
it it does feel like there was a
narrative crafted but my point in even
doing this story is just that there's
obviously
more to the story this is a kid who was
cleaning up
graffiti earlier in the day they do a
little interview with him from before
all this and it's like there are people
burning things down
attacking people violently rioting and
everything else and it's obvious that he
was not there
to do that sort of thing that doesn't
mean that he did every single thing
right but the video does show much more
of that
the idea that this video is offensive to
some people well it might be offensive
to some
people because things that go against
the narrative are offensive to some
people
but this obviously would lead us to a
much much bigger
discussion about online censorship and
everything else so
it's just it's just freaking messy
everything is messy and then you throw
big tech in it
and and man it just seems to get worse
um
you know interesting i'll just throw in
one other one other thing on the story
which is that
um i so i went on hannity last night and
then
not only did i reference in my little
hannity piece i said don't take my word
for it and sean actually led the piece
by saying
you know we want more evidence and all
that kind of stuff and you don't want to
rush to judgment and
that means you don't want to rush to
judgment either way you don't want to
rush to judgment saying
this kid's a murderer like cold-blooded
murderer and you don't want to rush to
judgment saying
that he's absolutely innocent the truth
might be in between he might have done
something stupid
and then also some bad things could
happen to him like we just don't know
exactly right
um but anyway so i i mentioned the 11
minute video in there i tweeted out the
the hannity clip and then a journalist
uh from the daily beast which is not a
place of
journalism uh just tweeted at me she
tweets at me every now and again tweeted
at me something like you know he killed
two people right
and it's like i'm not even gonna mention
her name because it doesn't matter but
it's like
this sort of rush to judgment by the
people who are supposed to be finding
truth
that's what your job is as a journalist
i'm not a journalist i have never
considered myself a journalist i don't
want to be a journalist
i see what's going on in the world i
tell you what i think i hopefully
give you something in some way that can
make a little that you then can make a
little more sense of the world that's
what
that's what i think if anything that
would make me an
analyst i suppose now as i'm doing this
but not a journalist
but that sort of lack of intellectual
curiosity
to see that someone posts a video talks
about it and that their immediate
response
has nothing to do with what's in the
video or does that peak a little
curiosity
within them it's just oh well he you
know he killed two people so that's that
you know it's like
this is why journalism is dying and and
i don't think
that it can come back at least any time
soon which is which is pretty
unfortunate
anyway there's obviously going to be
much more to this story the fact that
the
that youtube took the the video down i
mean man it just goes to the heart of
everything that is so
wrong with our system right now our
system of information and our inability
to trust
anybody in our and our our lack of
institutions
that are giving us the tools to see the
world clearly
so it's just it's just a mess okay the
second story that i want to do
i i think this is sort of the big one
that i want to focus on
for today because donald trump president
donald trump yeah
your president donald trump if you live
in america he's your president no matter
how much you don't like him
uh he issued an executive order
to get critical race theory
out of the federal government and then
he sort of expanded on that yesterday
now
what i want to do to set this all up
because i don't i don't like just like
saying words as if everybody knows
exactly what we're talking about well
yesterday uh before this
executive order i actually interviewed
chris christopher ruffo chris ruffo
uh who is one of the cleanest clearer
thinkers who has been
talking about critical race theory and
what is wrong with it and what
is it in the first place and he has
actually been working
with the white house and some federal
agencies on getting some of this stuff
out of our institutions so i interviewed
him yesterday we were going to hold it
for i think about eight days
till next week because we've just got a
whole bunch of content right now but
then when i saw
this executive order come down i said no
no we got to get this thing up
asap so we actually did post it this
morning it is up already so if you're
watching this you can watch
the full half hour thing unless youtube
took that down too because it's
offensive to some people
which i'm sure it is offensive to some
people actually that's probably far more
offensive to some people than
the written house thing but anyway i
want to show you just a quick
uh like a 45 second clip of our
interview just to give you a little
basis
of what critical race theory is then
we'll jump back in and talk about it
it's deeply anti-intellectual and it's
it's frankly racist i think we should
call it out for what it is
if you look at the kind of white
supremacist ideology of the 1950s which
we all denounce
uh it has the same categorization as the
critical race theory ideology of today
you reduce people to a racial essence
back then
and today it's whiteness and blackness
you create a group identity based
hierarchy
again it's different but it's the same
concept and then these critical race
theory trainings are essentially
denouncing people not on their
individual characteristics but on their
inborn identity
this is something that was wrong in 1950
uh it's wrong today
and we should be very on high alert and
we should all be working together to
jettison this ideology
okay so again if you want more on what
critical race theory is it's
it's a half hour interview i wanted to
do it a little shorter than most other
ones because i wanted to do something
that was kind of quick so that you'd be
able to ingest it and hopefully share it
with somebody so you have a sense
of what critical race theory is you know
to expand a little bit further
for for any of you that have been paying
attention to what identity politics has
done to this country uh
having it watched having watched it
destroy cnn
destroy the new york times many of the
places you do business
the idea that now racial quotas should
matter and we should have this amount of
black people doing this and
the oscars should have 30 percent
latinos and
remember all these things that actually
are racist it all comes out of critical
race theory that's why this story
is so important and you know for all of
the people that were talking about it a
couple years it's like
trump and this is the uncomfortable
truth for the liberals that i've been
trying to explain
to my good liberal friends of a few
that remain the few that remain um
trump is the one that actually does
things about them everyone else just
talks about them
but just having conversations about
conversations and talking about things
isn't enough so here's donald trump's
tweet from yesterday
he said a few weeks ago i banned efforts
to indoctrinate government employees
with divisive and harmful sex and
race-based ideologies
today i've expanded the ban to people
and companies that do business with our
country
the united states military government
contractors
and grantees americans should be taught
to take
pride in our great country and if you
don't there's nothing in it for you
okay so i want to remove that last
sentence for just a second i will
address
that last sentence because i think
there's some there's some meat there
that's worth exploring
uh but so last week basically he issued
the statement that said
federal government uh uh contracts
so first it was about the federal
government the the government itself
that they were not going to use critical
rate theory
critical race theory and now it's about
if you do business with any of these
things so the contractors right
now that's that's really interesting and
and it's
good you don't want this stuff in the
government
actually originally when this came out
the cdc the center for disease control
they said they were going to continue to
do it and then and then trump stopped
them from doing that
but the idea that would be if we allowed
critical race theory into the government
if we said that they were going to
hire based on race based on sex based on
gender
then you know what you'd have you're not
going to believe this guys
you would have systemic racism we don't
have systemic racism
right now we don't have a system of
government
that says you can't be hired if you're
black and you can't be hired if you're
white or a lesbian
or a [ __ ] or whatever else there is
okay we don't
have that you are you are hired based on
your skill
now that doesn't mean that some personal
discrimination doesn't exist within the
system just like
it doesn't mean that some personal
discrimination doesn't exist within
policing right
but there aren't laws saying black
people will get this punishment and
white people will get this punishment
and the for this now this idea of
critical race theory it was injecting it
into the system that's why i keep saying
the anti-racists the people who purport
to be the anti-racists
are the racists they're the ones that
make that are making everything about
race and not only making everything
about race but then trying to actually
build it into the system so this is a
very
very good move by trump now you know my
feelings on this i would prefer things
not be done by executive action
because what happens well obama did a
bunch of executive actions and george w
bush did a bunch of exact executive
actions before that and clinton and
everything else
and all an executive action is is
something that's temporary for that
administration and then the next
administration can come in
and sign something and then that can
override it so there isn't a lasting
sort of power to this right like biden
could come in
and and completely reverse this you know
trump got rid of title ix
also that that obama put in title ix in
effect was getting due process
out of college campuses if you if you
were a young man and you were accused of
sexual assault basically
there wasn't going to be a system of due
process anymore
trump got rid of that due process is
good we should give credit where credit
is due
these are these are just facts and i
know these are uncomfortable to my more
left-leaning audience
and and whatever remaining liberals
there are but but these are these are
the realities
of of the world as it is he's actually
doing the things to sort of
save the structure if if that makes
sense
uh anyway this morning i did a quick
uh look on twitter for uh for my liberal
friends right some of the
the idw crew i'm not here to throw
anyone under the bus people get busy
stories get lost but i did just like a
cursory look at
you know some of the people who have
been talking about the dangers of this
stuff for years
the lefties i'm talking about i'm not
talking about like shapiro who's on the
right obviously he addressed it right
and gave credit where it was due so i'm
not talking about him but i'm talking
about the remaining lefties whoever they
may be
pretty much nobody mentioned it nobody
mentioned that trump did something about
this
and i think this brings us to an
interesting spot
about about what trump derangement
syndrome kind of does to people you know
you can find a video that i did the day
after the election the day after the
2016 election
we didn't even have a studio yet at my
own house i'm sitting at a computer in
the backyard you can hear construction
going on
and one of the things i kept saying was
you know everyone needs to take a step
back because
if you keep calling trump hitler and you
keep all
calling all his supporters nazis it's
not what you're doing to them
or to him it's what you're doing to
yourself because you're painting
yourself in a corner and what happens if
trump ends up doing some basically good
stuff and in my view he has done some
basically good
stuff that's just the truth i didn't
even vote for the guy i'm going to get
to that in a second
um but that that's just the truth so if
he is the one
that is getting title ix out of colleges
if he is the one
that is getting critical race theory out
of our government institutions
you have to be able to give him credit
but the problem is if you've run around
calling him
an existential threat and hitler and his
supporters
nazis you can't suddenly be like guys
you know what that hitler guy
you know he's not that terrible and i
think that is the problem
with sort of the intellectual liberal
elite they have run around saying these
things for so long that when he does the
things that are going to save their
butts literally save their lives and
jobs
um and stop the mob from coming for them
and and fight back against the ideas
that they've spent their lives fighting
back against he's the one that's
actually doing something about it
then they go silent and and that's a
major problem so like even barry weiss
at the new york times she didn't tweet
about it yesterday and again i don't
mean this
or today or yesterday i don't mean this
to make it about anyone
but this is a girl who a liberal who
left the new york times because critical
race theory
identity politics all of these terrible
ideas completely infected the
institution that's that's exactly what
her letter in essence
was saying so she left the new york
times but she can't give
trump credit for doing something because
you always have to have trump
to be the bad guy and i've started to
work out a theory here
and i think it's something like this
whether you're a never trump
conservative
or you're sort of one of the good
liberals that remain
you sort of need trump you need trump so
you can always point to someone that's
worse than you
so it's something like this i was
thinking about um
you know guys like david frum and bill
crystal sort of the never
trump conservatives although i'm not
sure what makes either one of them a
conservative anymore
these are people who have been for every
war in the last 20 30 years you know i
mentioned it last week from is the guy
who who wrote the axis of evil line into
george w bush's speech which then got us
into the iraq war how many hundreds of
thousands of people died in that
um these are people who get everything
wrong but there's a beauty to having
trump
for them the beauty is oh well we're not
him
we're not that guy who eats ketchup with
his steak we're not that guy
and i think that's what's also happening
to liberals it's like trump's doing the
stuff
to fix the world to make the world that
you want to exist
a true a liberal order i know the
conservatives don't really want to hear
that but
but but a sensible liberal order that we
have had in america for so many decades
but instead they'd rather be invited to
nice parties so that they can sort of
think of themselves as the good guys
and trump is the real bad guy here
that'll that also goes back to that
harper's letter that you may remember
from a couple months ago where the where
the good liberals all signed a letter
defending free speech but at the same
time they also had to condemn
trump and it's like guys trump's not
coming
for your free speech he's not coming for
your universities it's the lefties that
are doing that
anyway this one just like strikes close
to home to me not not just because it's
the ideas
that i've been talking about for so long
but it's also just like
it's personal in a way because i can i
can really see the split
occurring right now it's like you can
either
choose to like kind of suck it up and
whatever you don't like about trump
understand that he's trying
to keep the wheels on the machine or you
can join the people who are going to
destroy you
but like be thought of as good for a
little while before they completely get
you
i don't know i think it's i think it's
fairly obvious uh which choice i've made
okay let's uh let's do one more thing uh
we've got an election
coming up there's a presidential
election joe biden
and kamala harris or kamala harris and
joe biden
versus trump and pence it's sort of like
a wwe event
election day is november 3rd we're
getting close people right we're
you know we're about five weeks away it
is going to get
more bananas if you think for a moment
that we are at peak bananas well i got a
banana farm i want to sell you because
it is gonna get more bananas okay
whatever you think is gonna happen even
this morning i i just saw this a minute
before we started there's some story
breaking about how
hunter biden got millions of dollars
from a from a russian
mayor or something like that don't quote
me on that exactly i literally saw it as
i was sitting down
i mean there's just gonna be more and
more uh the debates there's gonna be a
first debate next week
the idea that that these two are gonna
stand there and that biden can actually
stand there
for an hour and a half i mean it's going
to be just
just crazy television it's going to make
everyone
all the nuttier this is all with the
backdrop
of whatever is left of the pandemic
and whatever is left of the lockdowns
and everything else
it's also with the with the backdrop
of this supreme court nomination which
supposedly trump is going to nominate
someone on saturday and then we'll see
how quickly
the senate gets to it if you want to
know my thoughts on all that
my direct message yesterday i unpacked
that but in essence
trump has to go ahead and do it and uh
and the senate has to go ahead and vote
on it and by the way even though in the
previous segment there
uh i was sort of uh given given some
uh [ __ ] so to speak to some of the you
know the good
lefties i will say this i i on my quick
twitter scan i did
scan brett weinstein's twitter feed and
he said even
and this is certainly not a trump guy he
even said that you have to
do it you have to nominate because you
don't want a 4-4 court having to deal
with an election and that just seems so
deeply obvious
he was saying well you have to do just
sort of like a moderate that of course
is gonna
uh of course is gonna be nominated and
successfully confirmed
i i don't think that exists i just don't
think the game is played that way like
no
they trump could pick trump could
literally pick a pro-choice lefty at
this point and he'd have the democrats
voting against that
so i think there's a real politic part
of this but any event uh the election
is in five weeks i just want to
implore you guys even if you're
disgusted by all of this even if you've
never voted before
whatever it is make your voice heard
even if you don't live in a swing state
and you're in cali like i am make your
voice heard you know
this time that we're in is in such
upheaval and you don't
know what can happen one of the lines
that has really inspired me over the
last four years was the night of the
election i was on
uh i was on with the daily wire folks
and andrew clavin
after trump won right after trump won
and everybody was
shell-shocked right shapiro's head was
exploding everybody was
was shell-shocked and andrew clavin said
something that i think really
proves the brilliance and wonder of
america which is you know the thing
that nobody said could happen just
happened
anything can happen in america because
of how beautiful our system is
so if you're depressed because whatever
your side is is going crazy or you think
they're going to lose or anything it's
like you don't know how many other
people there are like you so good
things can happen i'll just tell you one
other story so make sure to register to
vote make sure whether you're going to
mail it in whether you're going to go
there know where your polling place is
all all of that stuff and i'll just tell
you one funny story about election day
last year
so uh we had we had moved as i mentioned
earlier which is why we were building
the studio
we had moved right before the election
and our polling place was
near our old house so we had moved about
about a half hour away
and we get in the car to drive to the
old to the original
polling place and i'm saying to david in
the car i don't know what i'm gonna do
and i couldn't believe it but i was like
i genuinely don't know what i'm gonna do
i think hillary is basically evil and
corrupt
but trump it's like could i possibly
vote for that and just the chaos and
like all of that stuff
and obviously my feelings about trump
have changed but at the time i was just
like i don't know what i'm gonna do i
can't vote for her i don't think i can
vote for him
and then it was also like you know
because i'm in california i have the
luxury to do whatever i want because
it's such a blue state
or the rest of it um and i had had gary
johnson on the show and and
of course he was the libertarian
candidate and i just felt like i didn't
want to vote
third party really because i was just
like ah it's it's just taken the easy
way out
and he really was not a good libertarian
candidate anyway
anyway we drive across uh across the
hill here
we get to the polling station we're
waiting at the police station i'm going
i don't know what to do
david's going you just have to make a
decision one way or another you got to
do something you got to do something
i don't know maybe i won't even vote
i'll vote on all the other local stuff
and then i realized that i was standing
behind rupaul and i thought
rupaul by the way not dressed as a woman
rupaul the man rupaul
um and i just thought this is just such
like a perfect
example of everything i'm literally
standing behind rupaul america's number
one drag queen
as i'm trying to figure out whether i'm
going to vote for hillary clinton or
donald trump like you can't make this
stuff
up if it was in a movie you'd be like
this is just too stupid
i ended up voting for gary johnson
because i felt that was the one i could
live with
but as i've said to you guys before i i
won't do that this time i will not
vote for the third party this time i i
think this election you know
everyone always says well it's the most
important election of your lifetime
every election is that
obama romney obama mccain you know bush
gore it's
everything is the most important
everything of all time this kind of is
the one
like this one is i think we can all
acknowledge
uh regardless of whether you're a lefty
or on the right whatever it is like i
think we can all acknowledge this one
is a little different than the others
right like this one is like
basically america's last stand uh before
we
dive into complete and utter chaos and
the choice is yours so i will not be
voting
uh third party although i should say um
i did interview joe jorgensen who's the
libertarian candidate and i think we're
putting that up in a couple days she
actually asks me at the end
uh who i who i'm gonna vote for or no no
she says to me did i win your vote
and then the last two minutes of the
interview are a little awkward
uh but i but i actually do like her and
i think she she's got you know ballpark
most of the right
ideas okay people get out there and vote
remember the critical race theory is no
good
and there's probably a little more to
the kyle ridden house
story and hopefully that 11 minute 11
minute video goes back
up that's it for now i'll unfortunately
be in the twitter world so you can catch
me there at reuben report
and i'll see you tomorrow